>>Linda: The United
States is at a moment
where it could really transform
its assessment systems.
Most of our testing is multiple
choice tests, pick one answer
out of five, which is
something you will never do
in applying knowledge
in the real world.
Our assessments need to
evolve to reflect the skills
and knowledge that we actually
value and that we need schools
to teach and our
children to learn.
>>Human beings are
naturally learners.
We are learning every
moment of every day.
In school, we have particular
things to learn and we know
that students learn more
effectively when we're clear
about what the goals are.
>>Chinasa: I kind of like, I
want like a goal in my head
about what to do with
information that I get.
So if they're going to teach me
how to do a one page equation,
I want to know what
can I do with that?
>>Erin: I look at the
beginning of the year and I say,
what are the big ideas that
I want students to know
in the whole year and what are
the major skills I want them
to be able to do?
And then I backwards
map those skills
and ideas into little chunks.
I try to have a really clear
learning outcome every day
that's measurable, so at the
end of class, students can say,
"This is how close I got
to meeting the outcome
for the day."
We use the language,
emerging, developing,
proficient or advanced.
If they know where they are on
that rubric, then I don't have
to own that for every student
and I think that's
really powerful.
>>Linda: Assessment should
occur early and often
and throughout the process.
>>Lisa: I do a lot of
formative assessments,
so formative assessments
meaning, it's not summative,
it's not a test at the end of
the week or the end of a unit.
You're doing a lot of small
check ins with the students
to see where they're at and to
see that they're growing a lot.
>>Teacher: How do you know that?
>>Student: Because I read
it in the Saturn book.
>>Teacher: In the Saturn
books, so you're making a?
>>Student: Connection.
>>Teacher: From text to?
>>Students: Tips.
>>Teacher: Very good.
>>Sheela: They are being
steered very gently
and very strategically, and the
formative assessment gathering
process is essential to that.
You really have to know what
kids know and don't know.
>>Linda: In a lot of cases, we
give students written feedback
on the paper that they've
written but then we move
on to the next thing and we
don't give them the opportunity
to actually rewrite that paper.
And the research evidence
is extremely clear that one
of the strongest positive
influences on achievement occurs
when students get
formative feedback
that they immediately can apply.
>>Chinasa: I think
that's one of the things
that the kids don't really
like, is doing the reflecting,
but I think it's actually one of
the things that helps us a lot.
I think doing it kind of
like helps you see the bigger
picture, because I don't think
that if I didn't do reflecting,
I wouldn't really think about
what I'm struggling with.
I would just kind
of want to move on.
>>Linda: Summative assessment
just simply means an assessment
from which we can
draw a judgment
about whether somebody has,
at that moment, learned.
A false distinction has
cropped up in the United States
which seems to suggest
that it's okay
for external summative
assessments
to just be multiple
choice tests.
In other countries,
summative assessments
that occur periodically are
essays and oral examinations
and project based assessments,
so that what you're able to see
about what students
can do reflects more
of what you actually want
them to be able to do
in the world beyond school.
>>Jill: So tonight
is exhibit night.
Every nine weeks, we have this
big celebration of learning
and the halls will be filled
with parents and children
who are all here to celebrate
what their children have
accomplished in the
past nine weeks.
We also use exhibits to assess
the learning of our students.
I like to go up to students and
have them explain an exhibit
to me so that I understand,
did they get the big idea?
Did they just do a project
or do they really understand
what they did, why they did it
and what it means in terms
of the bigger picture?
What we find is that because
the learning is so rich and it's
so meaningful, that our
students do very well
on standardized tests.
>>Linda: Many schools
that I've worked
with have graduation portfolios
where students have
to complete projects.
They often need to collaborate
with others effectively as part
of the work that
they're going to present.
They need to communicate
in multiple forms.
They need to be critical
and creative problem solvers
because they're going to run
into barriers and obstacles
and they have to
solve them in order
to complete this major project.
So the blend of the cognitive
and the non-cognitive skills
that result often in them
defending their work to a panel
of outside evaluators really
prepares them for the range
of abilities they're
going to need to have
when they leave the
boundaries of school.
And I think it's possible
to value these non-cognitive
skills throughout school
in the same way we value
the academic skills.
>>Erin: We try to bring in
people from the community
to watch or judge
their presentations
and then just do things that's
like, in your life, in a job,
you might have to make a
presentation to your boss
about why your proposal
should work.
>>Student: So ninety-one percent
of the people I surveyed said
that fifteen dollars for
one unit is a perfect price
for them.
>>Woman: Really nicely
done, good presentation
and I really like your product.
>>Erin: So trying
to model assessments
after real life experiences,
I think is really important.
No one in their job, I
don't think, has to bubble
in a standardized test.
>>Having a hundred and thirty
students means it's really easy
to have no idea if your
students are learning anything
because there's so many of them.
That's when in the last couple
of years, I've realized,
the more that I can get
them to take ownership
of their learning, then
I don't have to own
that for every student.
>>Student: Something that I'm
good at is researching in books
and interviews and
articles and to make sure
that the information
is accurate.
>>Linda: Ideally, assessment
is primarily for the student
and the student should own big
parts of the assessment process.
That can happen in
a variety of ways:
one is that they are continually
engaged in self assessment
and peer assessment,
using rubrics.
>>Student: So writing strengths.
>>Student: Creating good claims.
>>Student: And then,
areas for growth.
>>Student: I need to
analyze my evidence in depth.
>>Linda: When kids
have that opportunity,
they begin to value assessment.
Assessment is for me, as
a way to get the feedback
that allows me to become
the person I want to be.
>>If we do this well, the kind
of learner we should produce is
someone who is self-initiating
and self-motivated, understands
the standards internally
and is continually
driving towards excellence,
is continually developing
their own learning skills,
and is able ultimately to learn
on their own, independently
and collaboratively with
others, in a world that is going
to be very unpredictable and in
which those learning
skills are going
to be the most important
determinant of success.